things going wrong on stage but when you
talk about coverage it just sounds like
a litany of disaster no it was just I
was I was sick for I would say the
majority of that run and then wasn't
there weird thing with your contact
lenses what happened Oh both of my so
I'm I'm also just I have the worst
eyesight of any person I've ever met not
to brag and I've only ever lost one
contact lens at a time but on one
particular night singing maybe this time
I blinked and both of them came out at
the same time and I literally cannot see
and so in the blackout I was just
screaming bill who was our drag me off
in the dark because I just didn't know
how to get offstage I got sick a week
before we started and then and in
America I felt like Elvis they just pump
you full of steroids oh they give you so
many emaciated sticking that and it's a
pretty nihilistic character I mean you
go a bit mad anyway
no so that wasn't fun and then yes I
smashed my eye open on stage and I
supposed to be taken off the stage in
the blackout at that moment where you
have the spotlight and your eye on a
stage and supposed to come and get you
see you stand up and you just put your
arms out because you've been emotional
and someone comes to lead you off and he
didn't show up and then the train
station scene started happening I was
like I can't be here weeping in the
Train like and so I ran I just ran in my
mayhem into a metal pole coming who was
our emcee
good again then it sounded like a cart
like shooting metal anyway it split open
and had to stand up in that window it's
just blood pouring down my eye and then
do a curtain call they love this blood
on the stage went back on the next day
with an eye like that of the fake
eyelash like
[Music]